good evening and thank you all for being
here with us this evening today I'm
joined again by Caleb Kage the Nevada
covet 19 response director to my left
and there's Julia Peake to my right a
deputy administrator in the Department
of Health and Human Services in this
role miss Peake helped leading Nevada
statewide contact tracing efforts and
then pleased to have them both with me
here today to answer any questions that
you might have of them as you know
Nevada's continue to operate in phase 2
of our roadmap to recovery plan allowing
our medical public public health and
emergency response professionals to
evaluate and analyze new trends
including what is now a four week upward
trend in new daily cases we're still
watching and continued increase in our
confirmed and suspected kovat 19
hospitalizations as well recently that
number reached 400 in 39 cases in
Nevada's hospitals statewide however
patients requiring ICU beds and
ventilator usage continues to hold
steady
the Nevada Hospital Association is
regularly evaluating the effects of
kovat 19 on staffing PPE supplies and
bed capacity at this point the Hospital
Association continues to remain
confident that they can serve the needs
of all the beds I want to take a moment
to remind everyone where we've been our
goal for phase 1 was to flatten the
curve
Nevadans responded to the challenge you
were able to lift some restrictions to
go to phase 2 our role was to achieve 14
days of flat or decreasing positive test
rate and hospitalizations many
defendants acted responsibly and after
achieving those goals we opened reopened
much of our economy well there continued
to be some limitations bars restaurants
beauty salons and many other businesses
other employees back to work and opened
their doors a short while later we were
able to reopen our state's primary
industry tourism at that time I told
Nevadans to stay open and remove further
restrictions we had to accept our
personal responsibility to keep our
workers safe our families and ourselves
at that time I mandated that Nevada
businesses and employees who we interact
with the public
wear face coverings and continue to
strongly encourage members of the public
to wear face coverings as well
unfortunately as you can see from the
data that I've presented to you in the
numbers we've taken some steps backwards
clearly for many the excitement and
enthusiasm from escaping from our
confinement and finally being able to
enjoy dinner out with our families buy
new clothes or get a haircut
overshadowed the good judgment we
practiced in the previous months
unfortunately and inexcusably I also
made any error in judgment while out to
dinner with my wife where I was
photographed not wearing a mask it was
an ear and it was inexcusable to many
Nevadans have had the same lapse of too
many Nevadans that had the same lapse of
judgment every hour there are
photographs videos posted of large
unmasked clusters of people clusters of
potential kovat 19 spread so want to put
it to you like this if back in march
before we shut down the vast majority of
our economy if i'd have said to you we
can keep our economy open if everyone
agrees to wear a mask it maintains six
feet in person a person's distance
separation who would have not accepted
that offer
well that exactly is what needs to be
considered today I don't know why but
when protecting our health and our
neighbors lives became a political
partisan reven philosophical decision
for me it's none of those it's a medical
necessity a human obligation and it's
good for business
study after study worldwide every
notable medical professional from
president Trump's top advisor dr. voci
to all of our Nevada medical
professionals assert one unassailable
conclusion wearing face coverings save
lives period end of story in fact one
study highlighted by my medical advisory
team showed that replacing our strict
lot lockdown with social distancing
alone without universal masking results
in an unchecked spread with potentially
devastating results it showed that when
at least 80% of a population adopts
universal masking the results in a
substantial reduction of infection on
the other hand masking at only 50% of a
population is not sufficient to prevent
continued spread we owe it to each other
we owe it to each other to accept the
fact that wearing face masks coverings
saves lives we owe it to the many
workers the health care professionals
retail clerks restaurant workers grocery
store employees to accept that fact as
the truth we owe to Nevada's many
businesses large and small to accept
that fact my fellow in the beds I'm
offering us all another opportunity to
live in our risk for exposure and
infection and to keep our businesses
open and our economy moving forward for
Nevada to stay safe and to stay open
we must make face coverings a routine
part of our daily lives
that's why today at the recommendation
of the medical advisory team I signed a
directive with the new requirement for
Nevadans and visitors to wear a face
cover there to wear a face covering
their nose and mouth with a mask or face
covering one in public space whether
publicly or privately owned the
directive is effective on Friday really
is effective Thursday night at 11:59
p.m. to give businesses one day to get
we understand it's a situation in some
areas of the state is not as bad as it
is in others and we want to keep it not
bad in some of the areas of the state we
recognize that as well as all of the
work that everyone across the state has
been doing
however we see a spike in positive cases
and we need to ask everyone around the
state to do their very best to keep
everyone else at all of us safe this
especially applies to indoor activities
in which you are near other people
including grocery stores retail
businesses malls and gaming properties
detailed guidance is currently available
online at env health response NV gov
there are of course exceptions to this
directive for instance those with
medical conditions that make it
difficult to breathe those with a
disability that prevents them from
wearing a face covering and young
children between the ages of 2 & 9 are
exempt from this requirement however
they are still strongly encouraged to
wear a face covering as much as possible
the full list of exemptions is outlined
in the guidance online I encourage all
businesses are prominently post signage
to alert customers and help ensure this
directive is followed I know there are
some businesses who have already
required face coverings for their
customers and I thank you all for the
strong and helpful stance businesses
that fail to meet requirements in this
directive will face violations from
local licensing agencies and regulatory
authorities in addition to Nevada OSHA a
reminder as well that businesses have
the right to ask any patron to leave if
they are not following this directive I
call that local governments governments
and regulatory authorities to help
ensure there is education around this
directive for our businesses and
subsequent enforcement through the
appropriate bodies if compliance is not
met but it's not just on the business or
state local government it's on all of us
as well
I'm asking individuals throughout Nevada
to take this seriously and understand
the risk you're opposing on yourself and
others by not wearing a face covering
and I know there are probably a lot of
questions about additional enforcement
measures for individuals I want to be
clear this is a mandate so enforcement
language is necessary however ideally
there won't be any criminal civil
sanctions for individuals for
individuals the last thing I want is for
mine is for monetary fines or criminal
penalties to be imposed on the beds
which is why I strongly encourage
everyone to follow this directive that
is the state that prides itself on its
fierce individualism it's part of what
makes us great so I'm asking all of us
to take our independent spirit and turn
that into our individual responsibility
to keep the lights on for businesses
throughout our state's our state I
believe there are more good than bad in
this but I know that we've all seen the
concerning pictures of crowded spaces
since reopening they may appear
anecdotal for now but due to our
increasing efforts and contact tracing
they won't be anecdotal for long
increase contact tracing capacity will
continue to help us know where and how
people are contracting this virus and
will soon be able to pinpoint industries
and businesses where people who are
already risk are becoming infected with
the kovat 19-hour contact tracing makes
that possible I don't want to have to
take steps backwards by imposing
stronger restrictions on individuals
identified as high-risk if I don't have
to and the best way to prevent this is
to not let a business hyper industry
become high risk in the first place it's
on all of us Nevadans to be clear due to
the data in time needed for evaluation
of contact tracing and impacts of this
new phase covering directive any
discussion of entering phase 3 will be
tabled
the pandemic is not over as I said last
week we are not post over we're still in
the middle of the first phase first wave
of Cova so please I cannot emphasize
this enough where your face covering
anytime you leave your house when you go
to a restaurant when you stop at the
pharmacy when you enter casino where
your face covering you don't need to
wear an n95 mask like my medical
professionals where the medical advisory
team and CDC recommended homemade fabric
face coverings of all type they're easy
to make be made and they can be made
from cloth or fashion out of something
as simple as a bandana or an old t-shirt
options for doing so have been linked to
in our guidance there are several
additional resources online let's all
work together to stay safe and stay open
no shirt no shoes no masks no service
I know Nevadans are worried not only
about their health care but also about
their jobs and commerce they keep asking
me in my team what can I do to help you
can do this
everyone can this simple act is not only
a way for us to save lives but also for
way for us to save our Nevada's economy
and while I call this press conference
to discuss face coverings tonight I also
want to give you a quick update on our
state budget after all our state budget
and economy have been directly impacted
by the public health crisis as you know
the kovat 19 pandemic has caused budget
shortfalls for both the 2020 fiscal year
and the 2021 fiscal year major actions
to address the budget shortfall in
fiscal year 2020 included the
transferring of the rainy day fund
reversing one-time appropriations and
capital improvements and reducing the
operating budget by approximately sixty
seven point five million dollars these
were approved by the inner Finance
Committee On June 12th that brings us to
the projected shortfall for the fiscal
year 20
21 the latest revised revenue
projections developed jointly by the
fiscal analysis division and the
governor's finance office reflects a
total general fund shortfall estimated
at approximately one point to seven
billion dollars this is approximately
25% of our annual operating budget we
anticipate general fund revenue
collections for April business activity
will be released in the next few days at
which time the projected shortfalls for
both fiscal year 20 and fiscal year 21
will be updated in final actions for
both of my budget proposals can be
finalized with the most up-to-date
numbers here's what I want to emphasize
before I wrap up this is not a normal
recession the state went from its
economic peak to his economic trough in
a matter of weeks as a Matt as a result
tough decisions had to be made to save
lives revenues may very well recover
faster than expected
if the corona visor virus were to
subside due to responsible actions by
all of us or for treatment would become
available earlier than anticipated or of
revenues recovered more slowly the
second way of slow Z reopening of our
economy unprecedented historic uncharted
all of these words fit our situation it
would be irresponsible to release every
minute by minute revision of his budget
proposal without proper vetting by our
fiscal ex experts and before receiving
our latest revenue numbers with the
hopes of reducing the potential dramatic
impacts to our state budget I look
forward to receiving these numbers and
making any final adjustments to fiscal
year 21 budget proposal so I could share
it with all of you finally I want to
acknowledge some amazing Nevadans back
in April my office launched the year of
the Dead campaign recognizing Nevadans
that have gone above and beyond to help
their fellow citizens in response to the
Cova 19 band
we recognize medical professionals first
responders schoolteachers grocery clerks
citizens standing up donation drives
serving food and many more as the state
continues to reopen I'm excited to
launch a new campaign tonight to
recognize Nevada businesses that are
following directive guidelines to stop
the spread of kovat 19 tonight we launch
the battle board business campaign to
highlight the businesses taking creative
and safe measures to stay safe and to
stay open please send nominations with a
photo and brief explanation for the
nomination to battle board business
Nevada
that's battleborn viz and V at gmail.com
that's battleborn viz NV @ gmail.com at
this time I'd like to take a moment to
recognize some great Nevadans my staff
and I have briefed numerous business
leaders medical professionals gaming
executives and labor groups from
chambers of commerce to construction
workers to gaming executives to
hospitality employees I want to thank
you for your understanding your support
and your commitment to our shared
mission keeping Nevada open keeping
Nevada strong and keeping Nevadans and
our guests as safe and healthy as
possible I'm asking Nevada's tonight to
unify in an effort to move forward
Republicans Democrats non-partisans left
and right business owners and workers
let's do what's necessary not only to
keep our economy open but hopefully to
allow us to go full throttle in the
future safely and successfully anything
less than our total commitment will lead
to the terrible consequences we've all
seen in other parts of our nation and
the world thank you for your attention
and I now will be happy to take some
questions as a reminder if you could
come up to the podium and make sure you
hit the button to the microphones on and
let's try keep it to one question at a
time
so we can get through as many as
possible Thank You governor
as far as benefits go there are many
people who don't qualify for a regular
unemployment because their w-2s show
small amounts of say $100 and that
system doesn't allow them to file but
then they have issues receiving puah
benefits when almost all their pay falls
under self contractors what are they
supposed to do after a month of the
system being up and they're not
receiving anything they keep being told
dieter is working on it is there another
answer to give them at this point
for some guidance unfortunately there is
not another answer dieter is working
around the clock to resolve these issues
we've gotten to as many of them as
quickly as we possibly can unfortunately
the ones that are still having trouble
are usually an isolated case that they
have a specific instance that you're
saying regarding their wages or whatnot
and they have to be handled on a
one-at-a-time case-by-case basis and
working through them as fast as best as
you possibly can is there any way to
speed that up that process we are
working through them as fast as we
possibly can they have to be done
individually and it can take 30 to 60
minutes to do one claim which means
we've got folks that are in there doing
12 claims a day that's all that they can
get through a day and we've got people
that are using robo calls to call into
the teeters office which is jamming the
phone lines so other people can't get
through and it's making the problem more
complicated so we're getting to them as
fast as we could look as we can thank
you
when it comes to the contact facing do
you guys have any data yet that it talks
about the protests and some of the
businesses that have opened and then if
you do or if you do get some of that
data pertaining to certain businesses
that are opened would you roll back some
of the some of the regulations or
anything like that
I'll start with the contact tracing in
the data so we are analyzing the data
related to this we've added special
questions who our survey so that when we
do case investigation we can track if
they've been to a mass gathering if so
which mass mass gathering so we did pool
data from from June 4th to June 16th and
we recalled all those cases so
appreciate the patience of those cases
who were called approximately eleven
percent had been to a mass gathering and
twelve percent had been to a civic
activist event so that's something that
will be part of our normal screening and
hopefully can provide more updates on
that on an ongoing basis and with
possible rollbacks would that be
possible
well we've I'd hate to roll back an
entire industry but as we do if we find
out that for example bars are a lot of
calling is saying a lot of this or if
it's another activity that might be
causing some of the surges we will
definitely consider taking action in
those specific areas and probably have
to make some adjustments I'll just add
that we did also include now occupation
on our case are basically we will be
getting data on occupation as well as
places visited so we should have much
more robust data so that you can look
very specifically at those things and
just a reminder for the press coming in
the podium make sure you hit the button
so the microphone comes on thank you
hello governor we're about a week out
from the first of the month can you
offer people any assurance that they're
not going to get evicted in one week can
you say anything about when the eviction
moratorium is we're gonna be addressing
the expiration of the moratorium in the
next few days we've we're still
gathering some data and talking some of
the groups that are involved in this and
we should have an update for that in the
next couple of days Victoria do you
expect there will be some sort of ramp
down for folks that haven't gotten paid
their unemployment checks and just have
no money for this well there's a lot of
anecdotal stories about individuals that
you know have God had gotten
unfortunately haven't gotten they're
poor they're UI and definitely something
that we're considering and we will have
a phased in a rollback approach as it
relates to the moratorium on addictions
can you say when you guys will be able
to provide details about the plan in the
notice it expires at the end of the
month it would be in the next few days
they will be able to do that
I'm guessing the next three four to five
days thank you this button
this order is a mandate for folks to
wear masks the mandate is put on
individuals and on businesses we're
hoping that they will understand the
severity of the situation and
voluntarily wear masks it works I mean
every responsible medical profession
will tell you a mask helps reduce the
spread of an infectious disease
anyone who's denying that is just
denying reality so we will do an
education and we encourage businesses to
comply and we will use local business
regulating agencies in state OSHA to go
in and make sure that businesses are in
compliance with this directive and if
they're not they will face appropriate
penalties
I would hope that we would not get to
that point where I have police officer
Walker out of the ticket book for people
that's not what the intent of this is
and you're always gonna get people are
gonna say what about those one person's
not wearing a mask I want to get to the
95 percent of people that understand
it's in their best interest if you're
young and you're healthy it might be
okay for you but you could be an
asymptomatic and you're spreading it to
someone else it's important that they
understand that other people were a mask
for you you were masked for other people
we need to do a better job helping
people understand this it is troubling
and is really discouraging that this has
become a partisan issue about whether or
not people want to wear masks
this isn't about partisanship it's not
who you're gonna vote for for president
it's not about your rights it's not
about this is about protecting the
health and well-being of everybody that
you come in contact with that's what
we're talking about and we're gonna hey
governor I'm curious how much of this
latest increase in cases might be
attributable to the fact that we're just
testing a heck of a lot more people now
than we were okay increased testing is
not the sole responsible reason for our
numbers going up this right here has a
lot to do with why numbers are going up
people are wearing these that has a
significant impact the other thing that
has had an impact and it's on the
positive side the impact is the contact
tracing that we are doing it works if we
test a hundred people that just at
random you test 100 people you might get
a positivity rate of two three four
percent on those other people but if
you're testing a hundred people that
were identified through contact tracing
you're gonna get a much higher rate
because they were traced to this person
for example if you got it you were
infected and you identified that you
were with Meghan and ten other people we
tested those ten other people there's a
more likelihood that they could have
gotten it from you and that's why some
of the people are
think positive okay but but what
percentage again of the increase in
cases do we think is attributable to
just testing more doing contracting
tracing better at that sort of thing I
think as opposed to masks I think miss
Pete can give an answer that question
and then we will move to the next person
so I don't have that information with me
right now but I'll say we know the
equation to prevent it we also know the
equation to spread it and so all of us
can walk around the community and see
people without masks people indoors
close together and we know that's how it
spreads so now we know how to prevent it
and I'll also add kovat takes up our
entire lives now across the news daily
discussions and it feels so big but it
also ends up to be the individual
behavior that's going to butterfly
effect this is the governor mentioned
one person who's positive that gets in a
car with four people and those four
people get it and then those four people
spread it to four more people who spread
it to four more people who spread it to
four more people and it's attributed to
that first case who got in a car with a
group of four people so it's really
important to think about the individual
when it seems like this huge pandemic
and we as an individual can affect
change you absolutely can and that's
what we're seeing through contact
tracing it is the one person and it
spreads and it spreads okay thanks
the biggest thing you see when you see
the online and you've got the pictures
in your paper and you see them on social
media and you see fifty or hundred
people crowded into a bar nobody's
wearing a mask or they're walking
through a mall and nobody's wearing a
mask that causes an increased threat
it's that simple
thank you I want to go back to dieter
for a moment the directors departure on
Friday she cited threats to her personal
safety and that's happening in other
parts of the country as well wanted to
ask for your personal reaction to that
also our other staff state staff getting
those kind of threats and have you
gotten threats I I can't get into the
details about our security plan I've got
detail here with me and we've got a
whole team that tracks threats it's
unfortunate that Heather was put in this
position and sometimes people are just I
don't know if they don't think before
they go online and say some of the
things that they say or do some of the
things that they do but mr. corpulent
should never had to go through what she
went through and we're doing everything
we can to keep her safe and all of our
state employees safe timeline for
replacement hopefully relatively soon
thank you we have time for a couple more
questions for the governor hi so I know
in the past you've been reluctant to
enforce masks just because um we've seen
employees workers get harassed
experience violence are you worried
about the workers in nevada experiencing
that and what's in place to protect them
okay I'm gonna emphasize one more time
that wearing masks should not be as
partisan or an expression of your First
Amendment rights or your philosophical
views I would hope that people would
take this in the manner which it's
intended to please were a mask for
everyone's safety there have been
incidents across the country we hope
that doesn't happen here I encourage all
businesses to they're mandated they've
been mandated to have their employees
wearing them some of them are doing a
real good job of that and they are going
to face the repercussions of that as we
continue on our contact tracing and we
got our enforcement agents out into the
field to address this but everyone is
mandated to wear a mask
does that include law enforcement as
well when they're out in public that'll
be up to the individual law enforcement
agency as it relates to safety or an
occupation and you can find that all in
the directives that are posted online
okay depending on when they're making
stops and the enforcement of their job
some of the sheriff's and police chiefs
have opined that there's a safety issue
and we're leaving it up to the law
enforcement agency to make that
determination as it relates to their
specific job function go to the next
question there have been folks in
thank you good afternoon governor
according to covet act now it's a group
of healthcare professionals universities
researchers it talks about contact
tracing as of June
it says Nevada has cornered contact
tracers with an average of 334 new daily
cases we estimate Nevada needs 1670
contact tracing staff to trace all new
cases in 48 hours before too many other
people are infected
this means that Nevada is likely to be
able to trace 24% of new kovat
infections in 48 hours all these lower
levels of tracing it is unlikely Nevada
will be able to successfully identify
and isolate sources of the disease
spread fast enough to prevent new
outbreaks so we use that same math to
develop our plan for contact tracing and
so I could say right now our contact
tracers are available 24 from 8 to 8
seven days a week and their contact
tracing they have time to address the
cases and contacts that are coming in
front of them we also have around 300
folks through the Nevada System of
Higher Education that will be coming on
in the next couple weeks and I believe I
did fill out that survey and it was last
month and so that was accurate as of
last month so do you need more do you
need more tracers and what where would
they go if they say I'm really
interested in doing that great great
question so I would encourage folks to
look at the postings on our Nevada
System of Higher Education job boards I
know the one for Northern Nevada is up
and ready for folks to apply so that's
the best location and then UNLV and then
Great Basin College for our girls are
also recruiting ok thank you yep great
and thank you all for coming governor do
you have any closing remarks before we
go no I can take a couple of working
with okay governor says something take a
couple more she just
the announcement that we're gonna go to
maybe a blended learning model part
virtual apartment person for schools is
concerning a lot of parents who are
wondering how they're gonna afford child
care and how they're gonna be able to
work what are you doing to address those
concerns well that's an issue that our
superintendent Joan Ebert is dealing
with our 17 superintendents in terms of
how to handle that they're going to come
up with individual plans and
consultation with their school boards
and their parents and their teachers and
I support Joan's decision as it moves
forward that's something that they're
working on do you expect there'll be an
infusion of state money or anything to
help build capacity for childcare
there is no infusion of state money in
the budget crisis so we're facing right
now I'm confident that Joan and the
superintendent's will come up with a
plan that will work for everyone
thank you and we'll do Sam as the last
question okay yeah that's all got it
New York New Jersey and Connecticut have
implemented quarantine mandates for
visitors from high-risk States I'm
curious given Nevada's tourism industry
what it would take for you to implement
parallel mandates and for us well I'm
familiar I know those governors from our
National Governors Association meetings
Nevada is a state that's based on
tourism we're not gonna get to that
point because I'm confident that
everyone is going to follow the
directive and wear their masks and we
won't run into the same situation that
they had there I believe that if people
are responsible no shirt no shoes no
mask no service we're not going to have
that kind of an uptick and we'll
continue to welcome people from around
the country around the world into Nevada
and I want to compliment those
businesses especially the ones on the
strip and the businesses in Northern
Nevada that have opened safely in our
servicing their patrons are creating
jobs and in helping our economy and I
want to expand that and help that
continue to grow thanks thanks a lot
thanks for being here everybody
appreciate it